Gửi đứng đầu cộng hoa tác càst한, bây to vinh dự được đón thủ tưởng chính phủ lấy mình hơn
và đoàn đệ biểu của mấy đạo nhiều bộ ngành Việt Nam, sang thầm thành phố càst한.
Tinh tưởng chuyến đi sẽ mở giã nhiều cơ hội hợp tác, giữa cộng hoa tác càst한, nói riêng, với Việt Nam, và ngà Việt Nam nói chung.
Thủ tưởng lấy mình hơn, bây to với mình đến thầm thành phố càst한, cộng hoa tác càst한.
Đánh ra càu việc cùng hoa tác càst한 và thình phố càst한 đã chuẩn bị chù đảo cho hội nghị cấp cào a sàng ngà, với quy mù lớn và sự thông ra đông đạo của các lãnh đạo và chuyên ràng các nước.
Tinh tưởng rằng hội nghị sẽ tạo độc lực tiếp tục thuộc đẩy mạnh mạnh mẽ hơn nữa, quần hệ đối tác chiến lật a sàng ngà, nói chung.
Và quần hệ giữa các nước thành viên a sàng trong đó có Việt Nam với ngà.
Thủ tưởng chúc mừng những cái quả và chình kinh tế só hội, cải thiệt cuộc sống của người dân,
mà lãnh đạo và nhân dân cộng hoa tác càst한 đã đặt được thời gian qua.
Thủ tưởng nền mình hưởng cho biết Việt Nam còn tâm hực tác với các suy nghiệp công nghiệp bũ nhỏ của cộng hoa tác càst한
và chính phủ Việt Nam càng kết tạo mọi được kiện thuật lợi cho các suy nghiệp ngà.
Trong đó, có hưởng suy nghiệp tác càst한 kích rồi là mắn lâu dài, or đề tại Việt Nam.
Thủ tưởng chính phủ càng bớn chính quyền cộng hoa tác càst한 và cá nhân ngày mi gì khá nốt đã luôn quan tâm
tuy tiền tạo được kiện hết sức thuật lợi cho cộng đồng người Việt Nam tại tác càst한.
Hoàn ngày việc trong thời gian tới, cộng hoa tác càst한 sẽ tìm được việc phương Việt Nam phu hợp để thiết lập quan hệ.
Tìm kiếm câu ở hợp tác trong các liến vật thay đến có thể mạnh và như cầu như kinh tế thương mại giáo dục đồng tạo,
dù lịch vàn hóa. Thủ tưởng chính phủ đồng thời quyến khách các công ty hàng không ai nước quan tâm phát triển thêm